dopo quanti minuti ti sei pentito di
questo claim andiamo avanti
ciao ragazzi era tantissimo tempo che
volevo fare questo video ci ho pensato
molto ma credo che in questi mesi ci
siano state delle cose un pochino più
importanti sulle quali puntare la nostra
attenzione ecco perché prima di partire
per le vacanze ho pensato comunque di
fare così un piccolo aggiornamento su
instagram gli ho chiesto di farmi sapere
quali fossero delle domande che volevate
farmi quali fossero delle domanda che
volevate farmi visto che negli ultimi
mesi c'è stata una in particolare molto
molto molto molto frequente a tratti
mitragliante quindi bando alle ciance
direi di partire subito con questo video
vi piace parlare dei cap tuoi sincero mi
piace parlare di quello di cui mi va di
parlare quindi quando arrivano delle
domande per esempio come su questo
format
io faccio una cosa che si chiama
filtrarle ma è stato truffato da
pubblicità ingannevoli si ultima è stata
una pubblicità che ho beccato su
instagram sul sito queste jumpsuit
sembravano pazzesche e lo compra tipo 4
tutte diverse e in tutte e quattro
sembrava un sacco dell'umido è stato
difficile andare a vivere da solo
trovarsi da un giorno all'altro da solo
e non inventi sì la prima sera quando mi
sono messo a letto ed ero solo c'era
avuto il pensiero cavolo adesso io non
tornerò mai più
all'interno di un posto nel quale si mi
sveglio e un problema posso chiamare mia
mamma sveglia il mio fratello chiedere
aiuto a qualcuno a seconda se era stato
già da dio
dopo il suo coming out qualcuno a cui
tieni the navy ha iniziato a guardarti
con occhi diversi
ci sono cose per cui io sono
estremamente permeabile perché sono il
primo a mettermi discussione su queste
cose altre cose sono per esempio giudizi
legati a roba che non posso cambiare io
credo che sia bellissimo migliorarsi ma
lì sono i propri tratti le proprie
caratteristiche in cambiabili non ha
senso cambiarle auguro a tutti quanti
anni arrivare a questo punto ci si
arriva anche quando si ingoia così tanta
ma è l'unica cosa che puoi fare è certo
punto comunicarla tutta e non voler la
più mangiare come immagini l'azienda
creata insieme alla tua famiglia tra
dieci anni vorrei che fosse un impero e
vorrei che fosse composta proprio come
adesso da persone che mi fanno stare
bene con le quali lavorare bene immagino
si di avere tante altre persone simili a
loro ea me all'interno di un posto che
prima ancora di mettere il lavoro
davanti metta la persona posizione
preferita fare cosa e troppe ne vuoi
sapere angela peggior tuo difetto non
riuscire a focalizzarmi sulle cose allo
stesso tempo però essa è difficile pure
per le persone che mi stanno attorno a
rendersi conto del guglielmo è un
pochino una luce intermittente credo che
questo sia il mio peggior difetto ma
anche la mia più grande fortuna
cioè se io mi fisso su una cosa io
riesco a farla nella metà della metà
della metà della metà del tempo di una
persona normale il problema che non
riesco a fare tutto il resto coerente
non dimenticare anche di kakà
qual è stata la prima cosa che ho fatto
dopo aver fatto sesso la prima volta
pentirmene a cosa è dovuto questo
cambiamento di stile adoro i miei
piercing il mio cappello io ogni tot
tempo amo cambiare era da tanto che
volevo rifarmi loro solo che in passato
mi ero fatto questi buchi gli stessi non
so se qualcuno se li ricorda e sembra un
tronista maria sono venuto qua per di
vizia c'è una cosa così quindi li ho
tolti
senza contare che con una sacca di pus
tipo del collo che mi faceva sembrare
una specie di tacchino un rospo che
gonfia il gargarozzo sono andato al
pierce e che mi ha detto ma no a fare
una cosa un pochino più cioè da macho da
maschio o ste palle al pubblico che mi
ha detto non sono troppo grosse le palle
console troppo grosse alla fine mi sono
lasciato convincere la cosa bellissima
di piercing che poi sempre toglierli hai
mai avuto problemi di autostima se sì
come lei risolti orca
serie a io ho odiato un sacco di cose
legate al mio fisico prima tra queste il
mio corpo e che io volevo essere il
classico ragazzino super scheletrico
quello super skinny senza rendermi conto
che un corpo da manzo rugbista
praticamente io dicevo no le conosce
troppo grandi ma che ma sono bellissime
forno delle zambon quello che era
iniziato a cambiare il mio occhio su di
me è stato iniziare a prendermi cura di
me stesso con un po dell'elemento
mangiando un pochino meglio rendendomi
conto che c'erano cose sì che potevo
cambiare ma che al treno parte di me e
che quindi poteva solamente accettarle
deve imparare un pochino a piacerci più
di quanto ci piacciono gli altri che
altrimenti il parere degli altri
diventerà sempre un parere nostro e non
possiamo dare sto poteri alle altre
persone raga la quarantena mai fatto
molto bene
ci ha provato o l'hai mai fatto con una
ragazza no ho avuto varie occasioni
infatti io vorrei dire a tutti gli etero
che stanno là fuori praga fatevi almeno
un paio di amici gay perché le vostre
chance aumentano a dismisura perché
invita buttata dai consigli d'amore a
tutti e mo che il 6 di sicuro single non
dice che attua perché non ho bisogno di
consigli
qualche tatuaggio in programma vi
racconto questa cosa che vorrei fare
fatemi sapere sarà cazzata oppure no
vorrei fare un thermal che sarebbero i
piercing sottopelle tipo collanine ha
chiesto su instagram dei pareri e mi
sono arrivato un pochino di cose
contrastanti quindi sto pensando di fare
qua invece che il piercing un piccolo
tatuaggio tipo non lo so mandava la
senti di essere te stesso al cento per
cento dei contenuti che porti
assolutamente sì non sono il 100 per
cento dei contenuti che porterei che
porterei molti altri sono che
richiederebbero tanto sforzo tanta
fatica tanto tempo e altre persone che
mi aiutano ti penti ma di aver
intensificato il coinvolgimento della
tua famiglia il tuo lavoro mi pento di
non averlo fatto prima e qui arriviamo a
forse la domanda
amy è stata più rivolta negli ultimi
mesi stai ancora con luigi no qualcuno
di voi l'ha capito altre persone se non
l'hanno proprio capito infatti hanno
continuato a magari mandare che ne so
dei disegni dei messaggi carini
ragazzi questo lo dico a condividere
pezzi la propria vita sui social non
vuol dire che tu debba condividere tutto
quanto sui social le persone al di là
dei social mostrano quello che si
sentono di poter mostrare so che la
storia mia con luigi è stata una storia
che è stata molto visibile quindi era
ovvio ed era scontato che prima o poi ne
avrei parlato avevo solamente bisogno un
po di tempo sia perché dovevo processare
tante cose perché quando uno fa una
comunicazione questo tipo non sei da
solo c'è anche un'altra persona e deve
avere rispetto anche per l'altra persona
e sia perché è successo praticamente con
l'inizio della bbt dauno in quel momento
oltre a dover pensare alla fine del
nostro rapporto e o altre cose alle
quali pensare una pandemia globale
il movimento di blacklight smarter poi
arrivato il pride cose un pochino più
importanti di me temi sui quali
riflettere informarsi e di cui parlare
ha detto ciò io non smetterò mai di
voler bene e di male in un certo senso
luigi nel senso che quello che è stato
il suo coraggio nel mostrarsi nel
esserci la testa alta e stato di grande
ispirazione per me come persona che sono
sempre stato invece abituato a persone
che si vergognavano della propria
sessualità è che a volte pensavo forse
si vergognassero anche di me per questo
gli sarò sempre grata e la quantità di
messaggi che ci sono arrivati nel corso
della nostra relazione sono stati
assurdi e sono stati anche un deterrente
nel rendersi conto che era finita perché
quando gli dicono siete meravigliosi dei
pazzeschi redo all'amore grazie a voi e
ti metti in discussione pensi forse sono
sbagliato io a non vedere terminate cose
molto in cui sentimenti e cominciano a
cambiare a volte ci sono momenti alla
tua vita in cui tu hai bisogno di un
certo tipo di amore e il fatto che non
sia per sempre non vuol dire che valga
di meno quello tra me e luigi è durato
quanto doveva durare leggevo ultimamente
questa frase di schopenhauer che dice è
certo che un uomo può fare ciò che vuole
ma non può volere ciò che vuole quindi
quando si parla di ciò che vogliamo
abbiamo scelta di persone si trovano si
incontrano e poi vorrei fare un momento
nel quale si separano e si allontanano a
volte stare insieme una persona della
quale ti riconosci l'immenso valore può
confondere quella che è stima sicurezza
comodità con amore attrazione e voglia
di stare insieme di l ovviamente non ci
stiamo sentendo tantissimo pace
scriviamo ogni tanto ci mandiamo un
messaggio finire amore ma il bene non se
ne va mai via al momento si single si
ragazzi in passato sempre vissuto alla
fine di una relazione come un fallimento
personale e come un errore che doveva
subito essere riparato dovevo subito
trovare qualcuno rimpiazzasse quella
persona di cui avevo bisogno che doveva
stare vicino io quella persona ce l'ho
già
sono io dicono che amore arrivi quando
non lo cerchi ho sempre pensato che
fosse un qualcosa di fatalista c'è il
destino ti mette la persona giusta nel
momento in cui tu non la cerchi no
parlando con alice anche ne ha aperto un
pochino gli occhi su questa cosa mi ha
fatto ragione sul fatto che la persona
giusta arriva quando non ha cerchi e che
deve essere proprio giusta per farti
render conto in realtà hai un interesse
nei confronti invece sei liam indicare
affetto da chiunque anche la persona
peggiore del mondo che ti dice ciao
improvvisamente diventerà il principe
azzurro che mai sarà per te se dovessi
passare la vita con una persona meglio
uomo sexy ma scemo uomo colto ma
bruttino ora posso dirlo nessuno dei due
non era prescritto il medico dobbiamo
per forza accontentarmi nella vita a
livello sentimentale quindi nessuno dei
due la passo con me che sono frutto è
stupido scherzo la passione e sto meglio
ci diamo questa chiacchiera col come ti
senti in questo periodo della tua vita
sto bene sono pieno di persone che amo
ho la mia famiglia quella che mi è
capitata è meravigliosa quella che mi
sono scelto che è meravigliosa non
voglio mettermi in fila da nessuna parte
perché non c'è niente che io il momento
mi aspetti perché tutto quello che
arriverà sarà nel presente nel l'oggi e
il per sempre fatto solamente di tanti
oggi quindi con questo saluto e vi
ringrazio per queste domande